[Music]
[Music]
but it was a brutal day for all who
sailed their ships
all 800 seafaring staff made redundant
everyone from captains to cleaners
replaced with immediate effect
many found out aboard one of these ships
turning up to work as usual with no
notice or warning imagine hearing you're
losing your job with a recorded message
like this
therefore i am sorry to inform you that
this means your employment is terminated
with immediate effect on the grounds of
redundancy
and they must have felt this rubbed salt
in the wounds buses of agency workers
arriving to replace them immediately
some we spoke to had come from eastern
europe called up to the job just
yesterday
in hull and elsewhere they refused to
leave a sit-in of sorts and an act of
defiance
gaz was aboard when the news came
there's a lot of people upset a lot of
people angry and a lot of people
confused they didn't know where to go
next there was two zoom videos there was
one for officers and one for ratings and
the officers were given the opportunity
to join the contracted company that are
going to carry on the services on piano
the ratings unfortunately don't have the
opportunity
the pandemic has left piano in acute
financial difficulty it cited a hundred
million pound losses as part of the
cause it said it'd have no future
without these changes
not good enough said politicians they've
acted despicably they should be ashamed
and goodness me
i tell you if they don't change their
mind they need to
people will vote with a feat
staff leaving here today have told me
they've been left feeling shell-shocked
and utterly betrayed by the way this has
been handled and such a large layoff
with no warning or consultation is
reasonably rare and while disruption to
the wider port has been relatively
minimal so far that may be unlikely to
continue in the coming days this is
clearly a decision that's been taken
with financial cost in mind the
reputational cost may be harder to
resolve
not least because services will now be
suspended for a week to 10 days
for now backups here are no longer than
usual but travellers have already been
hit
you couldn't get through to innovate
everything was engaged uh your goals
or just ringing all
we were just abandoned all the
passengers were just abandoned
there were reports of security in
balaclavas removing people from ships
many others with no choice but simply
pack up their belongings and go
redundancies haven't been rare in this
sector the manner of these ones
certainly is